- Let's face it, work blows.
It's good to reward
yourself every now and again
in the form of browser tabs.
Generally I have
anywhere from four to 42
non-work-related browser
tabs open at any given time.
Let's see what I have today.
I have my standard Hampton
DeVille internet open
like a good employee.
I also have Amazon open.
It's not like I want
toilet paper delivered
to my house by the
time I get home today.
I do.
I also have a food
delivery site open
in case I want to order
lunch or a second lunch
or tomorrow breakfast.
I have Wikipedia
open because I forgot
what red panda babies look like.
And now I'm on a weather
site 'cause I wanted to see
if Mercury is in
retrograde so I can blame
all my problems on it.
Here's a tip.
If you get interrupted,
just pour hot coffee
all over your laptop.
Sometimes you just gotta react.
Happy browsing.